this is the grounded podcast number
eight with me I got echo Charles here we
got Andy stump here indeed and we got
Leah Taylor here kicking it doing doing
uh we're all in jujitsu
lockdown right now yeah well allegedly
kind of alleged allegedly in jujitsu
lockdown
is this like back in the day where you
know if you know that your friend is
clean then you can go ahead and get
after it
if you drive clean - yeah like you're
clean this girl you met she's clean well
we're good yeah or whatever the wire is
escaping me right now but what was it
back in the day where they abolished
alcohol prohibition prohibition yeah
this is kind of like that we have
speakeasies Oh Judy she's gone
underground cuz you can't roll in the
public you can't have you can't have 78
people on the mat just getting their
sweat on okay it's good that's a good
thing you rolled Majid you with a mask
on no yeah but no it doesn't help what
are you supposed to do okay for someone
that can't roll right now I saw a little
kid on the warrior kid like website did
you see this the kids got a blanket and
he like puts the blanket between his
legs like in guard and he makes little
arms with the blanket and he starts
working his Comoros right that's pretty
good yeah that's kind of the way to go
at this point I think people are getting
creative I've seen some videos of how to
make your own at home training dummy
yeah but mostly what I think is
happening is people are meeting up yeah
the secret handshake the knock the
location and time jiu-jitsu speakeasies
and they're getting it on that's what's
happening I think so cuz your school is
your academy club
okay have you been in it since it's been
closed I don't know if I were to go in
it while it's closed that would be
against the law has anyone here made
legitimate progress ever from watching
videos I'm too early I think day into
that but you haven't watched a video
been like oh I see how he's doing that
I'm gonna do that
No yeah I think what its gonna depend
right we're if it's like if you see a
technique that's like the answer to
maybe a question that you've always had
or something or like a a very specific
issue that you've always had defensively
or whatever and they give you
essentially the answer not necessarily
the answer so now you got to practice it
but it's like something that you already
know how to do physically but you know
okay let me do that at that time right
there standing with the detail perhaps a
detail yeah whatever like I think it can
be like a lot of things yeah yeah yeah
same so to solve a specific problem if
you have a certain level of jujitsu I
think it's harder to pick out yes the
bad videos because anyone with a cell
phone can make a jujitsu video that
doesn't make it good so it's yeah you
have to have a little experience to kind
of check I had a situation when I was in
Virginia Beach I was training with
Gustavo Machado
Guga sure good nickname yeah good new
guy so when I was training there I think
he gave me a like a video tape and VHS
yeah like a video tape edit Brown come
on that takes half your carry-on bag
right so he gave me like a videotape I
borrowed it for a few days and it was a
bunch of like championship matches or
whatever and there was one match I was
watching this guy and I wish I could
remember this guy's name but he was so
offensive in his jujitsu like so
attacking that it changed the way I did
jujitsu it changed the way I did jujitsu
from one video like I watch probably
like three of this guy's matches and I I
was like oh he's going for oh yes he oh
I was like wait a second I could I could
do that like I could start step maybe
not do that but I can move my game in
that direction and that guy was like a
he was a black belt this time I was
absolutely eligible did you say belch
yeah yeah yeah yeah well that's a lot of
times you know my Portuguese accent
comes out yes when I start talking about
jujitsu my my latent I'm learning a lot
about shooting last like four hours
before we go deep down they would you
did to rabbit hole I'm the newest person
at it at this table obviously I've been
at it for about 18 months
mm-hmm I have a question for you echo so
I'm behind the curve on a lot of things
that have happened in the jiu-jitsu
world obviously and I I was watching a
video yesterday but it wasn't technique
based and your name actually popped up
on it and I just wanted maybe some
clarification or explanation of this
video okay
it was called G in a game and my
question for you is what the fuck man
why didn't you shut that down at any
point in time that you were filming that
Oh rear naked choke Socrates Plato and
whatever that dude's name was he lays
out these people are some deep thinkers
and maybe this guy is a deep thinker I
don't know I don't know this person at
all
yeah but then at the end uh like has the
credits or whatever they're called
popped up I was like Oh Charles you even
have some explaining to do yeah so and I
think this came out like ten years ago
like I said it came out to me 24 hours
ago I don't know if that's good or not
no no that was a great production stop
it wasn't don't lie actually here in AK
we talked about this too because he sent
me essentially the same question right
when it came out so but he did say this
he was like hey the video production
quality was actually pretty I'll give
you that but you should have shut it
down due to the Conte that's that what
do you call above my paygrade yeah you
were probably on a daily at that point
this is a this is gonna end up being a
discussion about taking ownership for
things yeah I sit there and be like well
you know hey well that's not mine
at what point actually realize at what
point in that production that did you
realize you're like oh what's going on
here well you know artistic expression
has many forms you know some of them are
in that particular situation I was in no
position to critique judge or evaluate
overtly or I could have walked away at
any time here's what here's what I
thought oh okay this is what I thought
so when it came out I thought oh cool
this is gonna be really like right this
is a great idea which I would have
thought of this very funny thing right I
wish I felt upset and I live you know
you even if there's a couple there's a
little while in the beginning where you
like oh this is funny right because it
is funny to think about hey no big deal
I'm wearing my G I'm going to the
supermarket I'm wearing my G I'm going
to the club I'm wearing my G I'm going
to a parent-teacher conference right
that that could be very funny right yeah
and then probably I don't know how long
I don't how many seconds it was into the
video and even as I was watching it for
the very first time I was like when is
this gonna what is this gonna get funny
like when is this all gonna gonna tie up
and get funny and in the end you seem
like you tried to salvage it a little
bit with him trying to go to the club I
think you know I think that it was there
was a like percentage of it that was
that that was hey this isn't all like
real serious but I think me are you
talking about how a viewer might praise
of people starring and it didn't have
that I'm speaking factually I think I
think but I think if actually I think
actually said I think I'm speaking fast
yeah like I know it's true but I can't
prove that kind of thing um that's
called the Illuminati yeah yeah no I
think he was I think there was an
element of that where it's like it's not
a hundred percent serious but I think as
a result or at the way it turned out it
didn't come off so maybe the editor
filmer uh yeah my could have been my
fault yeah yeah well it was a again it's
one of those things that we can always
reach back to I always kind of hold that
over your head as as bad things could
happen yeah but here's the thing I think
I do feel like I mean whether you like
the song and I felt I felt very happy
with the video production bro I still
kind of do that thing cuz that was my
job yeah alright it was really the only
digits a question I had
you know you know it also might be you
know you can't surround yourself with
yes men you know you can't go through
life
well you can't well you can't but you
might have that thing that video okay so
you ever read YouTube comments on your
on your stuff I stopped recently okay so
I'm gonna talk about the reason you
stopped well I'm assuming the reason you
stopped so I've had you two in general I
would say I don't read the YouTube
comments not even the stuff that I put
out yeah well my point is that I've had
way worse reactions to my video of it
not like that is like really oh yeah
what item so I did this video called
bikini girl lightsaber oh yeah okay so
that's when you were you know this video
is your idea I think it was like the
leftovers of an idea that I had actually
it was we were making the podcast I know
that oh this is pre potty way too much
Liberty to watch one of the YouTube
comments said whoever made this video
should die like hey you know all the G
McGee comments or whatever mainly from
chaco now from you thanks by the way
yeah um you know those whatever because
he turned off comments real quick
oh yeah and took you down and everything
but I just had questions not a soul up
apparently well I think if I'm not
mistaken uh does it be inflated cop down
but yeah you know people downloading and
redo it and you know do you want to make
sure it's out there oh yeah it's out
there fully 100% can you look back in
like the jujitsu world and there's
certain things as time goes by where
things that were cool at one time become
lame obviously right yeah I'm super
stoked that there are no pictures of me
wearing a tinfoil gold affliction
t-shirt right because they're that I
know I didn't really would
I didn't wear it but but so many people
were wearing that stuff during that peak
of whatever and I will say I think I
became Danger Close on a few occasions
wearing walkout shirts like walkout
shirts for a fighter that I was
cornering where they were getting issued
these like super just what even call
that we call those things what this
should like is their name you know the
thing with an eagle and a tank and a
explosion and like kind of like one of
your videos on the t-shirts
I don't know that those shirts have a
name thank you my coach calls them scary
shirts yes something like that I think
yes skulls eagle wings or whatever you
did come close play any times with the
throw down situation yeah yeah yeah
there was one that was kind of had some
they look like little like little art
designs right yeah yeah all over a
throwdown yeah thing but no foil the
foil that was like the next Chanukah I
was like the tip top he had the foil
usually in the game oh yeah the flick
that's the other weird things you look
back at old UFC's and the amount of
companies that have come and gone that
were just trying to jump on any
including including including with and
starting with Tapout you know which the
guys from Tapout were freaking awesome
guys and the like the one thing I'll get
full credit those guys were man back in
the day they were we were we would be at
jiu-jitsu tournaments and we would be at
king of the cage fights and those guys
would be there when they talked about
selling shirts out of the back of their
vehicle I saw that like they were
legitimately doing they were totally in
the game so but then but I think that's
the only brand that could say that they
did that everyone else was just trying
to capitalize there's some other legit
brand affliction kind of like maybe got
a little hint
like maybe grabbed a little hint
there may be style and then was like hey
I like that element let's take on that
yeah and then they went and man now that
landed man that landed hardcore for a
while like just that whole style it was
weird to be in Vegas for a fight and
there'd be like dudes walking around
with like 350 dollar affliction genes
and then like what efficient jeans look
like they had like the shirts man yeah
or the dazzled yeah yes yeah no kid like
you're saying that like you're thinking
you're you're my 11 year old daughter
yeah you thinking you're making a funny
comment cuz you're taking it to an
extreme that wouldn't really exist it
existed before yeah and then there be
you know dude that was whatever he a guy
that had spent a bunch of time like
working on his hair you know I like
fully photo like yeah yeah you have that
whole thing yeah yeah that is true so
there's things in the digital world
though that you remember wouldn't
remember and how much does it still like
putting patches on your DS of your
sponsors yeah that used to be a sign of
like hey guys got a bunch of patches on
it just put a bunch of patches on your
gear or this do you know anything yeah
mental game first I'm not mad at that to
be honest with you no need say when I
was at when we're at Fabio Santos and
occasionally guys would come in from
Brasilia for the accent oh yeah they
from Brazil but but they would be and
this is I remember I remember
I wrote I think I actually framed this
up myself because if I wanted to
describe who these guys were test
someone else I'd say oh these guys are
always like I yeah there's couple brown
belts came in from Brazil from the and I
would say this as if it meant something
safe from the competition circuit I'd
say I throw there just to make sure
whoever I was talking to fully
understood what I was reckoning with I'd
say and just be covered in sponsorship
yeah and then you think you get a whole
sure of what you're doing with yeah as a
blue belt guy yeah well yeah I mean not
only does that like indicate that part
of it I think that's kind of where it
started and or as far as the feeling
goes when you see it that with the
patches just like yeah that guy
sponsored you must be dope you know you
must like win because you know you have
that in your mind and then after a while
it sort of just looks cool you know it
gets ingrained in your mind that's
that's like legit so it just looks cool
now and then um and then yeah as you
know more industries more brands came no
just wear my patch you know so you just
put patches on your stuff looks cool and
then and then you get the guy like when
you get the guy from a fob and he's
wearing the freshest you know gear
direct from whatever company and you
take one look at him and you go oh fob
it yeah these are the guys that you
assholes I do I spend that's what that's
what tactical assholes it's for those
guys yeah better Aylward
it's a real world in the world I come
from yeah they have all the gear but I
bet you can see it in the jiu-jitsu
world too like they might have all this
stuff but like that guy moves weird from
a distance like you can tell the guy
from the fob who you're like yeah your
magazines are in backwards and it does
cover still on there buddy like yeah
Roger that get the back control assholes
is specifically for that only for that
for me to make fun so you could make a
jujitsu assholes here's the thing Jiu
Jitsu has the proof right you have to
get on the match right and you have to
be able to you know you have to be able
to do the business so the FOB it will or
tactical asshole guy before I'm saying
like when he's just standing there or
walking around or whatever you saying
you can sort it you can feel it 100%
yeah so in jujitsu you can't really do
that unless he starts wrong he has to do
something jujitsu like physically like
that if you did like some wonky ass
warm-up yeah oh yeah but yeah but if you
just walking around he's coming in
shaking everybody's hand it's like you
can't really tell he has a bunch of
patches or no patches it's like man you
can't really tell but how fast can you
tell once you apply some pressure very
fast
right when you're basically right when
you lock up with it how hard does
someone fight to not tap to you when
when you see them you'll watch someone
roll and they'll like tap but then
they're going with you because you're a
female and there does not happen at my
school it's not a problem now but if I
go somewhere where I'm traveling you
know within SPG there's not many female
black belt so they'll kind of know who I
am or have an idea but if it's at a
different school very hard as the answer
real hard we have a female black belt
belt here named Marie and number one
she's awesome number two she's
unassuming about his on a suit well she
she's I guess she could be more
unassuming if she was really small but
she said she puts guys to sleep I would
say she probably has put more guys to
sleep than any other black belt at this
gym for that very reason guys they just
refuse they're not looking to tap to a
female yeah I'll tell you about five
nine yeah pretty tall I mean I would I
would imagine us enough still though I
think guys like with girls or female
partners it's like they don't want to do
it yeah that's a reality that's hard to
accept but now see that's dumb to me
that just reinforces the legitimacy of
what it is Jonas if you switch from a
male body to a female body and the
outcome was completely different and
they're doing the same thing like this
is this is dog shit that's why that's
why jiu-jitsu is awesome yeah I was
lucky because when I started to train
each there was no female so that trained
other than like my wife
maybe Susie you know Susie kids palenko
his wife okay yeah but yeah there was
like no females yeah I don't say lucky
but I never Desna said why were you
looking well it's lucky for my own ego
to not have to roll with girls when I
was or whatever 26 years old big tough
212 pound Navy shield getting tapped out
by a female I'll had the luck of that
not happening to me I was less lucky
but in the day and age you were training
there was plenty of men who acted like
females so yeah still were there yeah
yeah yeah no it's that yes it is 100%
just my ego was able to luckily get by
that because otherwise you know it's and
now this I will say to your point when
like let's say someone that's a lower
belt oh you got caught by a purple belt
yeah it's like yeah Jitsu works I tell
it to my I tell it to my training person
like hey judge it works if you do
jujitsu right it doesn't matter if you
put the right move on a black belt and
the black belt doesn't react correctly
you're gonna tap it you're gonna tap are
you gonna get your unbroken and put to
sleep that's the beauty yeah there were
a few people that quit early on my so I
was not a black belt yet but when I
started to be able to hold people down
and remember we were in one practice and
uh I held the guy in Mount the whole
round and I didn't really know many
submissions so I just held him down and
we you know we bump fists at the end and
he just got up and he got his gym bag in
the middle of open mat and just walked
out and we're like oh hey we're like
alright yeah yeah he's like see you
later he's like see ya we never saw him
again
that's when the ego is a destroyer you
know that's where the egos are destroy
because you can't handle that and you
decide instead of confronting that
problem your ego says just avoid it at
all costs and that's what that guy has
to live with your bag and your belt in
the trash can on the way out yeah that's
good though that that happened in that
that happens that's good because it's
obvious like and people can change for
sure but he's like therefore completely
the wrong reason you know so I think
that how much he's limiting his
potential by making that choice as
opposed to going headlong at that for
sure he's like oh that really bothered
me so maybe I'll dive into that and
figure out what it was instead he's like
you know this gym bag looks like it fits
get in the trash that's where that's
what you do to marys or mimics life
right if their attitude is everything
that you can't crush out of the gate or
anything that hurts your ego you just
run away from well yeah I think a lot of
guys don't start to especially now that
there's like the Explorer of an exposure
or has been for a while or whatever
they'll be like oh like like a
weightlifter type dude or something
I mean I call them in because I think a
lot of the times when we lift weights
and get big muscles it's like to kind of
cover up on the inside like what are you
saying you know you go from that you got
a little doing City the weird psyche of
echo Charles with it yeah for sure but
cover up Harker nonetheless it like yeah
so they'll they'll not want to start
they don't want to go to that to that
place of humility you know where they
got to be kind of a for lack of a better
term the loser some other end of the
spectrum Leah why wouldn't every female
just be like oh I'm gonna train this so
I can drop from dudes out well it takes
a long time so they have that idea when
they start and if they haven't been an
athlete before or they're smaller just
the the open mats are really hard you
know you're just spending a lot of time
on the bottom you're getting tapped not
necessarily with jiu-jitsu but just size
strength speed they get injured more so
it's a challenging first couple years
you know we have a women's class to help
offset that and I'll have some ladies
that'll just roll in women's class for a
while till they learn more of the
structure and survival skills and then
they can transition out of that so if
you're if you're gonna give advice to a
female starting jiu-jitsu what would you
wear are some like pointers you would
give them pointers I would say pick your
training partners and open mat so I tell
the ladies to try to warm up with a
colored belt to pick training partners
within twenty to thirty pounds of them
if possible if they don't know who's on
the mat to watch one round and you can
see who's rolling really hard and you
don't have to roll at those people so I
just basically you don't have to roll
with everyone and to advocate for
themselves have five or six people in
mind that they want to roll with hit
those people and if someone comes up to
them in between that isn't on that list
or is way out of their weight class and
usually what'll happen is it'll
a really big new white belt and a female
that's left over because everyone
partners up and no one wants to go with
the giant white belt but no one wants to
go with the girl either so you would be
surprised how many times that matchup
happens so I tell them you can tell them
you want to get a drink tell them coach
Lea said they're not on your list or you
know you can just sit around just tell
them no I'm sorry you know I'm not up to
training with you today so I just I tell
them to do that and some of them are
confident enough to do that and the
longer they role the more able they are
to do that but at first you know I
literally had that talk with a woman she
was standing on the side of the mat like
she was just about to jump into a shark
pit you know she was so nervous and I
said we'll just pick your training
partners you know and I turned around
and she literally was paired up with the
biggest white belt one stripe white belt
in the mat I yelled at him and I said
what are you doing that you picked her
and he said oh she looked like she
needed a partner I was like you look
like you need a rest I was like you're
gonna play guards the whole time and I'm
gonna look at you like this while we're
rolling and she's gonna pass your guard
and you're gonna let her you know have a
decent round so it's just yeah and if
they do pick partners like that they'll
develop a skill set and survival skills
and the mindset to be able to roll
bigger people but at first it's just I
don't know how much you're really
learning you know with five minutes
straight and cross-eyed bottom remember
bottom man that's a good that's a good
little tactic right there where you make
the instructor like okay if you're
talking about like if they're it's a
mixed class right yeah where you as the
instructor can be like hey you know you
female or or a group of females or
whatever here's your list of people here
that you can roll in you can be like
that guy that guy and then so they can
be like so they don't have to face that
big rejection situation they don't have
to be like oh I'm not gonna roll with
you you know because some people that
even that is kind of intimidating they
always you don't know and so but they
don't have to do it anymore they can be
like oh I'm sorry like the coach it has
a list for me you're not on the list
sorry you know and it's way easier
that's a good little tactic I want them
to just stand up and walk to their next
partner that would be ideal just get up
and you know upper belts are fine
because even if they're bigger they'll
control their weight they'll control
their technique so you know once they're
above like purple belt that's fine but
I'm gonna ask you if you distinguish
between Bluebell
yeah because that's a big job it is the
chances of a purple belt you know going
nuts on a on a female or or a new
partner or whatever it's pretty small
chance of a blue belt Wow might get a
little psycho yeah actually for the for
the smaller people to roll with you know
hopefully yeah I don't feel a difference
though there's been plenty of purple
belts who lose their goddamn mind on me
I met you rolling with smaller partners
oh yeah everyone tries to remember most
people hold you and still six six six
foot purple belt let's say cuz I'd say
this would kind of go into the realm of
maybe more often losing their shit on
you as far as purple belts go yeah if
you're a big athletic Navy SEAL did you
that last word that you just used is a
huge problem yeah so and you you'd think
like oh yeah that's just maybe an
occupation where but there's a certain
persona I think generally speaking
whether it applies to you or not but
that's what you are actually so they
when they go in they're like oh I know
this guy's already tough so I thought
it'd go hard and then when they go hard
as we all know it's like you can't most
of the time you can't just go harder and
be more effective most of the time so
they're gonna go hard it's less
effective so now they're losing their
shit I understand what happens and I get
the the Navy SEAL thing we were just
talking about this you know that episode
that our accord with Jocko it from one
you're never gonna put it down but to it
people look at it and they may not
necessarily understand that there's a
broad spectrum of individuals inside of
that community good and bad and
everything in between but it 100% puts a
target on your back whether or not she
wanted I get hit up people hit me up and
say hey man come train in our gym and
we'd love to have you I'm like no I'm
not I'm not gonna come and be the
bullseye that walks through your gym
yeah you're like oh yeah we're gonna
have a Navy SEAL come in like yeah yeah
I'm not a Navy SEAL anymore but out for
six years I didn't do any jujitsu while
I was in the color of my belt that's the
KO of the belt that I have I don't have
a fucking Harry Potter wand that allows
me to like do anything special and yeah
yeah that's the truth but in there my
you do so when yeah when you come in
like think about it any any little thing
when you get introduced like then
wherever I don't Callum entry school
whatever they're gonna say baby seal and
everyone's gonna be like maybe seal so
that's just full disclosure if they come
at me hard I will also go back at them
hard so it's equal to my board no ya
don't have that sandwich as well yeah in
a way though like I think as a white
belt Navy SEAL or not I think it's kinda
the upper belt streets if in fact we're
trying to avoid that kind of situation
for like a brute we're it's uh it's more
up to the upper belt I think cuz he has
more capability of controlling I think
well I think I'm gonna take some
ownership off your plate on that one any
weird house I'm just saying when it
accelerates I'm like alright I'll dump
it into fifth gear to talks about
leaving your ego at the door is so much
of it revolves around you going and you
know I give the same advice that you
give Lia to females I give to like you
know a 56 year old guy that wants to
start you Jitsu you should absolutely
start jujitsu it will be awesome you
need to pick your right training
partners you need to put your ego in
check to say no to people I'm horrible
about that like I'll have a injury right
and I'll be like I'm just gonna train
with Annie and echo today cuz those guys
know that if they get whatever like if I
go hey stop you know then they'll be
like all cool that doesn't mean that
they won or not gonna jump up and
celebrate where but then some guy that
you know of good but not quite as good
maybe super strong and they'll be ok you
want to roll and I'll be like yep the
back of my head I'm like God you just
you're stupid and I've gotten bit by
that a couple times where I've gone with
guys that up like you know had a little
tweak injury and then I go with someone
and you know someone that's good
athletes strong you know decently decent
level of skill and I know I shouldn't be
training with them because I know you
know I'll come in the Gymkhana hems
gonna go just kind of kind of mellow
roll today and look I can have I can
have crazy I can have quote mellow rolls
that last one hour with Dean or Andy or
echo that are
total like no one on the outside would
be able to look at it and go like all
that you know that they're kind of just
there kind of just cruising a little bit
but for both me and them they know like
oh yeah we were just cruising that's
nobody you can't see the pressure see
the pressure but you know someone's ads
on the sidelines watch and goes looks
like jock was getting after it today
okay let's go yeah and what that guy's
thinking is today's the day if you have
a target on your back at all times yeah
yeah so today's the day and they're
gonna dive for something that's the
other thing is they can dive for some
move the low totally low percentage move
and if they don't get it cool they lost
a jock oh no big deal if they get it bro
Hail Mary Hail Mary on some move they're
gonna crank it yeah they're gonna crank
it and you know what when you guess what
I should do
crank it back freezes time yeah that's
what I should you know Abby I knew for a
quarter-century somebody gets me caught
in some move I should be that cool tap
but what do I do
yeah I even do that when I'm so is that
the ego that prevents your hundred
percent so let me ask you this because
this is an interesting thing I've been
thinking about you they say that jujitsu
is very humbling and it's strips that
you go away but as you advance in it I
feel that some of the higher belts will
develop the ego back again yeah and you
got to be very careful of that and where
I see that manifests itself most clearly
is when people don't want a role right
that's the most that yeah the most clear
manifest manifestation of that to me is
is for me if I go in and one of the pipe
hit and younger guys that's really good
says hey you want to roll and I go oh
you know not today you know if I had
that happened the other day with Wes and
you know I just got done with a bunch of
rounds and Wes is like hey you want a
roll and I'm like not really and he's
like oh okay and then like 10 seconds
passed I was like bro let's go yeah I
mean like I know this is gonna be a
crappy round for me but you know
whatever yeah and it's not like wes's I
mean Wes is a black
and he's a beast you know and I was just
like oh that's my ego talking saying oh
you know you don't want to have a tough
around you don't want to get tapped out
by Wes so I'll just sit here on the
sidelines that's where you go that's one
shade of ego or just responding poorly
if things don't go their way yeah yeah
whereas it's like you know you were
talking about if there was a list in
here of people who had tapped with the
checkmark next to it every single time
like you'd have more than everybody I'm
aware that's okay right like I mean to
advance in the sport you'd have to
continue and learn those lessons from
that tap yeah but I think the ego
especially when there's a difference
between the color of the belts oh yeah
or on how dumb is an expected that
doesn't go that particular direction
yeah everyone like pretty my I would say
99 it's closer to a hundred percent of
people than it is 99 percent of people
won't like when a lower belt taps them
out if they're really going you know
like if we're really training and
whatever in the lower belts tops a mom
or a rival that you have that's the same
belt as you that you always get or
you've always got in you know so and
then they get you for the first time or
whatever you in the second time really
um everyone no one likes that like
everyone that's a thing for everyone in
their mind now how they physically like
reason is that so oh yeah how they
behave after that that's gonna reveal
like how much unhealthy ego they have
here's some great advice from Jeff Higgs
on this topic and he told me this a long
time ago if you tap out someone that you
don't normally tap out when you when you
shake hands and go again like right then
you better be ready for them they're
gonna come after you like up like us
like just a savage
oh yeah that's what's gonna happen oh
yeah and that in think about it that's
true for like have you ever had that
happen to you where a guy comes after me
yeah oh yeah okay so here's the question
house have you ever done that to
somebody else for me
got you I'm sure I how he was like all
thinking like oh let me think every
single time so that's this house and I'm
speaking from experience to where
someone would that get me and I'm like
brah
because that is hundred percent true
like where where if you can it we all
want so you thought you got me huh here
oh yeah that's what I'm doing this to
you
well I've never tell you get a good move
on me or something or you get an
offensive move and then I go no I it's
more I don't believe that hesitation I
think we all know that like if I don't
know Andy or something like this you're
gonna bring it right after cuz just we
know your personality this Andy's a bad
example cuz we go back and forth you
know what I mean there's no there's no
yeah now but then what clarity story
should say that the end of you're
talking about is not sitting just so
nobody is yeah we are not talking about
me yeah no I of course of course 21st I
guess I I guess we'll go no hesitation
of course if someone gets me I'm gonna
step it is someone that I if it's
someone that I haven't although I don't
know
I've had people tapped me out where I've
been like okay that was nice man yeah
that was nice there's a nice move
yeah to say I don't believe that and you
know maybe not be true so I get maybe
you know but I don't know I don't know
well I'll tell you who does that is Dean
Lister what oh if you get if you get him
yeah well there's two ways he reacts so
one is like he'll just be like whatever
and kind of blow it off and he's having
a bad day and he just he just kind of
survives the rest of the time and then
like leaves yeah but if it's not that
kind of day and I catch them in
something but I'm about to just not only
just I'm not only am I gonna get tapped
out I'm gonna get I'm gonna get punished
capital child yeah I'm talking I'm
talking things you wouldn't if you you
would if you saw Dean beating me up yeah
like if you were like okay if you if you
came to the gym and you happen to catch
let's say I just caught Dean and then he
was one of those days where he who
wasn't having that
you would be watching thinking that it
was not true you'd be watching it going
like this could this isn't why doesn't
Jacque or do something what's wrong with
him
like what's his problem why is he why is
he playing around like this and the
reality is I can't do anything as a
human that's 230 pounds that's been
trained trained jiu-jitsu for 25 years I
can't do anything I can't are you trying
everything I can I can't do anything
that's that's that's an awful awful
awful thing yeah yeah yes I mean we're
talking when he's belittling me like
making fun of me like slapping me around
and and and and belittling me and I
can't do anything about it that's I have
a question leo and I asked this because
when I think about like my wife or when
my daughter kind of grows up where if in
the event of them training with other
other men because there's a lot of types
of people that come in and train
jiu-jitsu and not even a skill aside
just types of individuals do you get
weirdos ever are you talking like
perverts yeah like it just yeah Morgan
took that from Theo von to know but yeah
yeah and I mean or whatever just someone
like weird like hey your weirdness is
going outside of the acceptable Jiu
Jitsu kind of context you know very very
occasionally I that goes more to mat
culture so it's again the the coach or
the leader in the gym has to police the
mat and be willing to correct those
people or throw them out of the gym and
there are your training partners in the
mat will do that as well you know but
you also have to be willing to say
something and I've had women have really
really really bad roles and then they
don't tell me or they'll quit you know
they'll tell me six months later you
know I didn't go to open mat for six
months and all kind of coax them back
onto the mat and they'll be they'll tell
me they had a really bad role with
someone what do you mean a bad role a
role where maybe the person didn't try
to submit them but just held them down
in a way that was made them feel really
out of control didn't didn't work to
improve the position
and just kind of laid on them in a
creepy way kind of mountaintop yeah yeah
just just kind of okay what do you what
are we doing here like are we just gonna
lay on each other for three minutes I'm
just gonna look at it when you started
you Jitsu how long did it take you to
get through or over or around the close
body contact with sweaty dudes I had
done a bunch of traditional martial arts
before so I had done a little bit of
contact I'd done some throwing you know
I keyed Jitsu and so I'd done a little
bit of the contact and then so taking
that next step it was it was a little
bit weird at first for sure but I was
the only girl you know at my Academy for
quite a while the first time I rolled
with another female was at a competition
I mean but that was how everyone was you
know they're people think oh if you're
you train with men all the time I said
well that girl does to believe me you
know there's not especially you know
what the black belt level it's like they
all they all train with guys have you
ever had a specific experience with like
someone who's creepy um I've had people
get a little bit fixated you know as
I've been of Coach that's happened a
time or two yeah yeah just wanting to
train with me specifically more than
they should you know I've seen men
specifically choose only female partners
though so it'll be that'll get you
kicked right out of me a minority on the
merit and they're only partnering with
women and you know so that was something
that would happen or just trying to
message me you know over Facebook oh
yeah what's starting to creep me out is
echo just keep asking these questions
about this oh yeah yeah I got I got
three daughters and you know two of them
are older now but for sure they kind of
grew up with jiu-jitsu you know so they
never had to enter into the jiu-jitsu
world like cold turkey that's why that's
why I asked you about it because I know
a lot of females I mean you show up if
you show up for a first jujitsu
classroom you don't know what to expect
this is a freaking hole that you're not
ready for this
you just do it like really like personal
space barriers and boundaries your first
class is a nightmare
yeah that's especially if there's guys
involved for girls that's 100% different
if then if it's like mixed or all guys
have that idea of all female classes
especially for beginners cuz after a
while they don't care anymore
you know after a while they don't there
should be about one a week I mean the
other thing that'll happen is you'll get
women wanting to Train because they've
had some trauma you know they've been
assaulted and for them to partner with a
guy is just not gonna happen
and so jiu-jitsu becomes unaccessible to
them so I've had some women you know and
they'll have a panic attack on the mat
you know and sometimes it's not
appropriate for them to do jujitsu first
they need to go through some trauma
counselling but I've had other women
that if they're partnered with women or
they're training with women at first
they can overcome that and kind of work
out of it yeah I was gonna say we've had
some females that have done just that
you know the first thing was like hey
look I'm not getting on the mat if
there's men on the mat yeah no it's not
happening and then over time it's like
they're rolling with men because they
realize but it takes it takes some time
it takes some getting used to if you
were gonna take a ten-year-old girl I
think actually 10 year olds too young 10
year old girls they don't have the
they're gonna be fine rolling with boys
no factor no 30 or 40 yeah it's 13 14
where you start how would you how would
you introduce a 13 14 year-old girl is
it hey let's find a female let's find a
place that has female classes only well
i coach actually most of the teens and
kids at our academy which is straight
last gym autumn I can't Montana and we
have kids classes for ages 3 up through
16 and my teen class I have about 40
kids in there and a good portion of them
are our girls so it's awkward at first
but they're all kind of awkward you know
at that age they're just all sort of
uncomfortable so we partner them with
other females in the class if we can and
try to partner them with you know kids
who've been there a little bit longer
just so it's it's they can work through
it quickly you know we give them time to
socialize so they can kind of make
friends do you put him in a gear
mediately yes I'll tell you that might
sound like a not a big deal but like
when it comes to wrestling
and you know you're in a singlet and you
know you're 13 14 year-old girl said
nightmare it's it's yeah the guy I think
is a good place to start with young
female sure they're all geek classes and
I do have some women that don't like to
roll without the key for that reason
wait for one reason just it's another
layer yeah yeah a little too close
contact if they feel kind of exposed or
uncomfortable it's too much body to body
contact yeah yeah the end part of the
reason I asked too is that as a guy
who's like into jujitsu we don't think
about that very often like because no
one's gonna be creepy to me unless they
are they got to be really creepy for me
to even notice you know but like murid
would tell me about stuff that happened
at other places or whatever and they
have like nicknames for certain guys
like oh he's whatever and he's and they
have nicknames for these creepy guys so
why do those creepy guys why are they
allowed to stay i I don't know because
at some point right so and again
everything that I say about jujitsu put
it through the lens of 18 months of
experience but what you're about to say
is correct if there's a creeper in the
gym your weaponizing their creeper
mentality because it's just like any
other tool this ridiculously large
butter knife for example could be used
to cut butter or it could used a lot
well you can really lop somebody's head
off with that you'd have to use the back
sewing side of this but that's a
different podcast yes sir some greater
evil some of them are really subtle
about when they do that sir they're very
careful about who's on the mat but if
they have been talking about the females
the men the creeper Mary permit the guys
who are yeah who are have bad intentions
though wait until there's a coach maybe
not directly on the matter directly
watching them they'll do things you know
in transitions to and from locker rooms
or in parking lots you know and this
isn't stuff that necessarily happens at
our school but you'll see on women's
Facebook's or forums that they've had to
leave a school because sometimes the
student that's harassing them has been
there a long time and they have a lot of
social credibility and they're not
treating the men obviously the same way
that they would treat the women and so
sometimes the guys won't think it's a
big deal or they just don't want to
believe that that person would do that
and especially if the females newer it
just becomes a
he said she said things so it just goes
back to Matt culture you know what do
you allow at your academy you know how
do you allow people to talk to the women
there do you have a women's class do you
have a children's class usually that
stuff isn't gonna fly there you know if
you walk in it's just only dudes only 20
year old dudes rolling on a mat then you
know there's a reason for that
so Annie were you gonna say that
teaching these creepers jiu-jitsu is
it's a tool right it's weaponizing
you're not even that guy a skill that he
shouldn't have well and so my
understanding of digits at this point
right it's you're you're learning how to
control another human professor if you
empower somebody who wants to control
them for an other than honorable reason
are you not increasing their
capabilities yeah absolutely yeah but
but that's a lot more rare that happens
for sure yeah where that's kind of their
goal you know whatever to be like I'm
gonna impose myself like on that level
that's what we'll call that level 10
right that's way more rare than this the
spectrum or this certain side of the
spectrum of the subtlety so in it we'll
just say on one side of spectrum there's
like super subtle just like maybe the
guy giggles more with the girl when he
rolls something inappropriate
not even that yet if you go that's a
level 11 and here's why I say the giggle
because I rolled like I never really
roll with girls just by happenstance but
so I roll with his girl night you know
she was there for jujitsu she wasn't
there to hook up she wasn't there to
flirt shoes are for but she would giggle
like I'll let you know one like
something you know she just kind of
giggle in the transitions and I remember
thinking this is wildly inappropriate to
be giggling at me right now like this
you know it really threw me off so that
sort of made me narrow sometimes laughs
and you roll but here's the problem
you're good you're about she's laughing
at you out done
like whatever she was loading up is
about the doors about to close on that
yeah
and yeah you're good it does that to you
read the one black girl she'll giggle -
like when but but if you have a name
what if you have a nickname which is
probably through repetitive behavior
that level is that yes yeah so you know
you're talking down the spectrum but
before you get there where you have a
nickname
yes to me in my opinion anyway I don't
know these people with the end course or
whatever but um when you're at that
level oh yeah you should have been out
of the gym long time ago but there's
many different levels to that and then
so it's like where do you start saying
hey do you tell the guy hate don't
giggle that's inappropriate and make him
feel like he's some like predator or
something when it's like dang bro I was
like I didn't realize I was doing it you
know he had no Intendant so it's it's
hard to sort of get that spot on on the
spectrum and then make us you know take
a stand at that put at an appropriate
point because you don't know where in
fact that is and then you get the fact
that some most guys I think anyway maybe
I'm Navy I don't know but most guys
don't realize they're doing it they
think like oh maybe this girl likes me
or whatever
well maybe I'm gonna give this girl a
compliment you know or something like
that and then they say then the girls
like oh this guy's giving me like
compliments on my eyes or something like
that and he's thinking that he's doing
the right thing you know fantastic guys
by the way that's good eyebrows to go
into there's a lot of like creepy things
that guys can do like if you look in
someone's eyes while you roll with them
but seems weird oh I don't think I don't
play any of these games I will take
every advantage that I can possible I
mean why can't you lick somebody during
the role I guarantee you you'll get out
of whatever position you're in that's
level two that's level ten hey it works
yeah thank you back with that subtlety
it's kind of like man it's it's kind of
a weird kind of scenario because
especially when you get guys who don't
realize they're doing it fully or they
think that it's not that big of a deal
genuinely don't think of it or think
it's that big of a deal
you know so I think like is to
acknowledge it and openly and honestly
have a discussion with that person
possible you don't need to do that or
whatever hey I'm not wrong do you
because the way you just did that you
know what's really sad about this is
like okay I got I got daughters you know
three daughters and one son and
obviously I've thought about it at
particular moments of their grappling
careers if as it were but like girls and
females are just dealing with this all
basically all the time you know like
like you're basically like this never
comes up right does never cover echo and
I never ever say like have you
hold with bill he's kind of creepy you
know I've never I might say bill stinks
or bill whatever but you're not saying
like hey has he ever like you know kind
of made some adjustments in your guard
and like no that never had that
conversation and I remember seeing a
some kind of some kind of documentary or
something about being a female and they
were going around asking like when's
they asked a bunch of men when's the
last time you were scared never and the
guys like well you know like six years
ago my car broke down and there was a
gang fight going on and there was rounds
flying overhead and I ran for cover but
the rounds were impacting right next me
I was pretty I was sweating that and
then you know then asked the next guy
and he's like oh there was a bank
robbery and you know that's what a guy
thinks and then they asked a female like
when's last time you're scared they're
like Oh Tuesday night I had to walk to
the car Thursday night I had to you know
okay and you're like wow yeah it's it's
a different reality it is ya know it is
and I think what you can do is learn to
protect yourself the best you can you
know I'm learning to shoot now too so
I'm working on that you know we have a
black belt that was a long time police
officer and he's just like learned how
to fight at every range learn how to use
weapons you know make yourself really
difficult to kill yeah that's and that's
where I was going where this is like -
for someone because I'm sitting here
thinking man if I was a female I'm
listening this I'm thinking you know
part of you thinking oh I'm never going
to go do jujitsu if this is what it's
like but that's the absolute wrong
answer that we already talked about like
the answer is no you go you train you
learn this look you have to give that
warning that there's gonna be perverts
out there the vast majority of people
you're totally good to go it's totally
not the norm I'd say don't let the
anomaly paint your experience so like I
said it matters when you walk in if you
see a kid's class if you see women if
you see female coaches you know it's
gonna be fine when I went up when I
walked in my coach's wife was there and
she's a brown belt now and so it was
just I asked him cuz I was a little bit
worried I said is this is it okay that
I'm female you know you only have five
or six guys on the mat you know they're
all rolling no Aggie I'm like is it
alright if I train here and he said yeah
why wouldn't it be what do you mean yeah
that's the disconnect right guys yeah of
course so he had his wife take me aside
and I said well is it am I gonna get
beat up you know do they not want
girls here and she said no why why would
you think no it's gonna be fine no it'll
be fine then I was like okay so I got on
the mat and you at that point you just
you roll the first day you come in now
we have a beginner program you know it
kind of easy on in but they're like you
just get on the mat and wrestle so yeah
it was
he just kept a really good culture and
all the guys you know I had tough roles
but I never was afraid I was gonna get
hurt nobody was inappropriate or creepy
or anything like that you know I had I
had a really good experience coming up I
mean it was physically challenging was
mentally challenging but it wasn't I
didn't ever feel unsafe they became some
of my really good friends I mean some of
us that started together still work at
the same Academy under my coach you know
their black belts now it's so they're
you know there's some of my closest
friends yeah the other thing that comes
up is well what this stuff really work
for a female like a small female in a
you know going against a meth-head
that's 240 pounds or whatever and my
answer is always well if there's two
things two parts us how long does it
take to learn this stuff right well my
answer that is when when are you gonna
get attacked right sure if you start
jiu-jitsu on Monday and you get attacked
on Wednesday it's not gonna be a lot of
good but be better than nothing but the
bottom line is you know that I used to
say this in the SEAL Teams when they
were pushing all these weird like
martial arts things and one of the
reasons behind using these weird martial
they're like well you can teach this in
a week and I'm like hey first of all you
can't teach very much about fighting in
a week and second of all you're in the
teams for twenty years you got time
let's learn something useful that's part
number one and part number two is look a
hundred and ten pound purple belt in
jujitsu female against a two hundred and
forty five pound psycho meth head he's
gonna win and and now look if he knows
absolutely nothing sure but you gotta
you gotta figure he's gonna be able to
overpower her that being said and this
is why I say you start training and you
never stop that that guy it might take
him if she doesn't know anything he can
have her pulled away in a van in three
seconds if she knows jujitsu it's a
two-minute fight and in that two-minute
fight the cops come people get the
license all these things happen you
delay that for long enough and most of
these scumbag
the last thing they want to do is have
to get into a fight and so that right
there the other thing is if you've never
been grabbed before if you don't know
what that feels like you can't even get
through that shock you won't even make
you won't even react in any way
whatsoever when someone grabs you when
you do jujitsu that's every day and
you'll know immediately you'll see
openings you'll be able to do things so
you can forestall something really bad
happening and that's why I think even a
110 pound purple belt against a
245-pound psychopath that guy's gonna
pick another victim after about 14
seconds of like wait a second what just
you know all these things are happening
really quick and then you add in you
know you see the cheesy videos of like
well I'll do this I strike and that'll
stop the attacker and and you go oh that
anybody that knows anything is about
fighting knows that hey if I do an eye
poke on you it's not gonna end the fight
because for a small time but if you're
in a real situation and you take a bite
out of someone's cheek or its bite off
their nose like I had a friend that bit
off a guy's nose and it was like you
don't think about it but it's in kind of
a fight ender like you know how as a
boss moves it's a it's a Power Move and
so now you put yourself into a situation
you know Dean used to say this Dean used
to be like hey if I know jiff I'm a
black belt in jujitsu or a purple belt
in jujitsu and you decide you're gonna
bite my cheek well then I'm just gonna
punish you for it cuz that's the only
thing that you're you did we talked
about this before we had a guy Igor
who's a team guy and he was in a street
fight and got his ear bent off not off
completely but a legitimate bite was
taken out of his ear mike tyson's yeah
look bigger than a Mike Tyson yeah
actually there's a pretty big party
tonight
yeah and he uh and like the guy bit his
ear and then he was you know the guy
that bid it the guy that bit Igor's ear
was on the bottom paying for Igor was
and so he's always been across side and
like that that ear bite didn't help
anything but if you've reversed those
roles like if you know jiu-jitsu and
then you start adding in biting off
people's noses or whatever it can be
effective in making a assault
that would take three seconds for a
245-pound guy to get a hold of an take
up girl and put her into a car whatever
can turn that into number one of scrap
number two like a two minute evolution
and number three a possibility that this
guy just says hey dude I'm not putting
up with this right now this is what I
this is what I signed up for I teach a
lot of women's self-defense programs and
the first thing we walk on is actually
or work on is actually just teaching
them to walk how they carry themselves
their body language it has a lot to do
with victim selection and once you learn
how to grapple or if you're an athlete
you tend to carry yourself differently
and you are far less likely to be
selected as a victim so we literally
just work on posture and eye contact and
how are you sitting who are you're
surrounding yourself with so just
avoiding those bad situations before you
get into it and then we do a grappling
based self-defense program where it's
just escape and you have to be able to
run at that point you have to be able to
be in good enough shape to fight as hard
as you can to get out know a little bit
of technique and then you have to be
able to run so if you're not healthy
that's going to be really challenging so
you know we teach you have to take care
of yourself you have to take care of
your body even if you're not going to
become a grappler or a fighter you need
to be strong so we really instill a lot
of that at the beginning yeah that's
awesome well it's been an hour we're
usually trying to do these things for an
hour and not six hours or five and a
half hours Andi mmm Thanks yeah thank
you
Leah thank you thank you Eko you look
whatever this is if you want to support
this podcast then go to Joe Coast or
calm or go to origin main comm and other
than that stay grounded